this is what was left of the HD piece
headquarters in Ankara Turkish
nationalists torched the building
overnight party officials accused
authorities of supporting what they call
a campaign of lynching and say they
didn't provide sufficient protection
uncle Emilio despite talks with the
Ankara police chief and governor the
number of police officers who came here
to provide security was limited all the
groups simultaneously attacked our party
broke the windows and entered the
building they set the second story on
fire where we kept electoral documents
dr. m0 party returns in blundell many of
the Nationalists were enraged by the
latest wave of attacks from the PKK
separatist group the attacks in the
country southeast have killed dozens of
Turkish troops in recent days
nationalists accused the HTTP of being
the political wing of the PKK across the
country more than 120 buildings
belonging to the HDP were attacked
according to the party turkey is less
than two months away from new elections
now the HTTP warns that the
deteriorating security situation in the
country's southeast will make it
difficult to hold the planned vote